hello and welcome to math simplified
i am dr umar malik and i hope all of you
are doing well
in this video we'll be talking about
tina cruz
better known as jokset
tina cruz or jock itch is a fungal
infection that causes a red
scaly and itchy rash in warm moist areas
of the body
the rash often affects the groin the
inner thighs
and is usually shaped like a ring jock
itch
gets his name because it's common in
athletes
it's also common in people who sweat a
lot or who are
overweight although often uncomfortable
and bothersome jock itch is a very
common condition
and usually isn't serious but keeping
that in mind
never ignore any disease and always seek
medical help
at the earliest hence it is very
important to treat it at an early stage
because if not rated in the early stages
it becomes very difficult to treat later
on
as the topical drugs that are used for
the treatment of normal fungal
infections of the skin
fail to act effectively at later stages
of the disease
fungi thrive in warm moist environments
so this type of environment can cause
them to naturally overpopulate
the same fungi that cause nail
infections athlete's foot
and drink worm can cause jock itch these
belong to a group of fungi known as the
termatophytes
trichophyton is the most common
dermatophyte
involved in jocket other dermatophytes
that may be involved
are epidermophytin and microsperm
before we get into how to treat jock
itch let's first look at some of the
factors that
increase your risk of getting jock itch
jog itch is especially common in summers
and rainy seasons
because this leads to increased sweating
and temperature
which are ideal conditions for the fungi
to grow
if you wear tight fitting and synthetic
clothes that
occlude your body and prevent air
circulation
this also increases the risk of getting
these fungal infections
sharing towels or personal clothes with
other people can also increase your risk
personal hygiene is very important and
habits like
not bathing regularly and not breathing
after sternous workout sessions or
exercise
also increases the risk of getting these
fungal infections
if you have untreated fungal infections
at other parts of your body
the fungi can spread from those areas to
the groin and cause an infection
having a weak immune system or diabetes
also increases your risk of getting jock
itch
now let's talk about how jock itch or
tina
presents and what symptoms you can
develop
jock itch is typically found in the
groin inner thighs
or the anal region also it can be
located
on the lower abdominal area symptoms
include
itching and burning a red scaly
circular rash with raised edges
scaling flaking or peeling of skin
in the infected region the rash usually
begins with a reddish area of skin in
the crease of the groin
it often spreads to the upper thigh in a
half moon shape
the rash is usually ring shaped and can
also have small blisters
it may burn or feel itchy and the skin
may be flaky or scaly if you visit a
dermatologist they can confirm the
diagnosis by performing
a few simple tests the first basic test
usually done is skin
scraping test the doctor scrapes the
edges of the rash and
observes it under the microscope to
check for the presence of fungi
these skin scrapings can also be sent
for fungal culture test
in most cases the dermatologists can
easily
identify jock itch and they can promptly
start the treatment without any tests
now let's look at some lifestyle
modifications you can implement that
will help you to prevent
jock itch in the first place keep your
groin
area dry dry your genital area and inner
thighs thoroughly with a clean towel
after showering or exercising also
remember to dry your feet after taking a
bath
wear clean clothes change your underwear
at least once a day or
more often if you sweat a lot
undergarments made of cotton
or other fabrics that absorb moisture
and keep the skin dry
also help to prevent this infection
always remember to wash your
workout clothes after each use
make sure your clothes fit correctly
especially your undergarments
avoid tight fitting clothes which can
rub and irritate your skin
and put you at an increased risk of jock
itch
try wearing boxer shorts rather than
briefs
don't share personal items don't let
others use your clothing
dolls or other personal items also don't
borrow such items from others
control any athlete's foot infection to
prevent its spread to the groin area
now if we look at the treatment itself
it can be divided into topical
antifungals which are applied
over the skin and oral medication
topical medications
include soaps body washes lotions
creams and gels we will look at them one
by one
and see which one is best for you
topical antifungals are the first line
of treatment for the patients of
chocolate
the most effective topical antifungals
include drugs like
azoles which include chloramazole
ketoconazole
oxyconazole and certaconazole another
very effective category of drugs are
allylamines
like tobinophene and butanophine and
there are some newer antifungal drugs
also like
cyclopirox and selenium sulfide which
are proving to be very effective for the
treatment of jog set
you can start the treatment with a soap
or body wash
containing clottery muscle one percent
or ketoconazole two percent
and use that to wash your body every day
when you apply the soap or the body wash
make sure to leave it on for a few
minutes before you wash it off
so as to have the maximum antifungal
effect
you can also use cyglopidoxolamine or
selenium sulfide body washes
next we move on to the antifungal creams
gels or lotions you should use
again similar antifungal drugs are
present in these creams and lotions
like ketoconazole two percent chloramus
all one percent
laliconazole one percent eberconazole or
certaconazole
selenium sulphide 2.5 lotion and
cyclopirox one percent cream
are also very effective you should apply
these creams and lotions twice daily
once in the morning
and once before sleeping i have provided
the links to some of the best
anti-fungal soaps
body washes creams and lotions in the
description box down below
so make sure to check them out as per my
experience as a dermatologist i have
found
lalal one percent cream selenium sulfide
and cycloperoxolamine creams to be quite
effective in the treatment of
jock itch the treatment with these
topical drugs should be continued for a
minimum
of four weeks if you have a mild
infection
and if you have a severe infection
involving larger areas of the groin
upper thighs or abdomen you should
continue the topical treatment for at
least
six to eight weeks oral antifungal drugs
are indicated in the case of extensive
involvement of the skin
and in patients who fail to respond to
the topical therapy such as creams and
lotions
now there are three main fda approved
anti-fungal drugs for the treatment of
teenagers
these are terbinophene etroconazole and
fluconazole
these drugs act by inhibiting certain
enzymes in the fungi
that are important for the fungi to
synthesize their cell wall
without a proper cell wall these fungi
cannot grow
and they soon die out out of these three
fluconazole is mainly indicated for the
treatment of
vaginal candidiasis oropharyngeal and
esophageal candidiasis
while itaconazole and turbinophene are
mainly used for the treatment of tinia
and we will focus on them itrochonazole
is available
in 100 milligram 200 milligram and 400
milligram doses
fourteen year crore is usually 100
milligram twice a day
or 200 milligram once a day for
two weeks is the minimum you should take
this drug
tabinofen is given as 250 milligram
tablet
daily for two to four weeks
these drugs are usually not available
over the counter
so you need a prescription from a
dermatologist
while undergoing this treatment make
sure to take proper care of your hygiene
and wash your clothes regularly with hot
water
also make sure to iron your
undergarments before each use
as many of the times these fungal spores
can get deposited
on our inner wear clothes and this can
cause frequent relapses and treatment
failures
so that was all about jock itch and its
treatment
in the coming videos we will discuss
about tinea pedis
tinea capitis and many other topics
related to fungal infections
as these are very common in today's
population
also i am going to make some videos
regarding home remedies
and natural methods to treat tinea
infections so make sure to subscribe and
hit the bell icon
so you don't miss out on those videos
thank you so much for watching
if you found this video helpful make
sure to like this video and also
share with someone who you think might
find it useful
bye bye and see you in the next video